hey gq i'm noah schnapp and i'm going
undercover on the internet
this is actually me
[Music]
youtube and we're gonna have to watch
this
no no no miller aye cloudy asked millie
is actually noah's mom i swear
yes that is very true millie has been
known to kind of
mom me around when we're at dinner
she'll like order for me sometimes and
stuff
and it's great it's like a second mother
i love milly
hi i'm finn wolfhard and i'm millie
bobby brown and i'm noah schnapp
next up we got bailey carson with a
hundred thousand likes on the comment
asked why is noah the only one dressed
like an actual teenager honestly
i don't know i mean we all have our own
styles we all kind of dress
differently i guess finn's more of like
a cool edgy
rock guy and billy's like very put
together and then yeah there's me
hey guys i'm back and today i'm here
with venus williams
next up we got laila berry asking noah
why have you stopped making videos we
missed them it was like quarantine and
then i kind of like
got really busy so i stopped posting on
my youtube channel but i've been making
a lot of videos and i filmed one like
yesterday so
and i just reached out to a bunch of
people
for to make a youtube video like next
week which is really exciting so
look out for that would you happen to be
a stranger things fan
rita noor asked do you prefer nose hair
how it is in stranger things or how he
has it now
i prefer it like now because it's just
it's easier to manage it's shorter it's
better
my dad i think had a bowl cut when he
was little and then he cut it
so i don't know i don't know where what
this bull cut is but
hopefully we'll cuts it soon next up
instagram
stranger things fan page asked please at
noah schnapp just tell me when will
stranger things come out
we're starting filming now i don't know
when it's coming in
will.martin asked how do you know
charlie dimelio
last year like a year from now when she
was just kind of like getting her fame
i slid into her dms and i said hi and i
said like
you seem cool like we should hang out
because she lives she used to live in
connecticut near me
um and then she responded like noah
what's up and we got each other's
snapchat we started talking and then
months later we coordinated a collab
and fun fact she was actually the last
person i saw
before the lockdown happened posted
andrea olivo 09
asked wait i'm confused i thought they
were not going to film cause corona
virus
so we started filming in february or
march or something
and then literally on the first day it's
our second day a corona lockdown
happened
everything shut down we all were in
quarantine and then we've been waiting
since march to start filming
moving on first up twitter
andy asked why did i just find out noah
schnapp has a twin sister i do have a
twin sister her name's chloe
a lot of people are surprised when i
tell them that we're kind of similar but
she's great to have around and i love
her why did that person just find out
maybe they saw her on my instagram
or on tick tock because she has a tick
tock too and she posts a lot with me
belle lasker asked going through tick
tock i think that noah schnapp is the
best celebrity as he usually responds to
most his fan base
that is so nice i really appreciate that
so much i try as hard as i can
to reply to as most people as i can and
my friends usually send me like tick
tocks about me so i can comment on them
but
it's sometimes it's hard because like
for one period of time i started
replying to everyone
and then my whole for you page became
like all about me
and then i like i couldn't escape myself
on my tick tock so i had to like
take a break from it for a little bit
but i try my best to reply to everyone
clamill warrior asked why is it that
i've had a crush on noah's snap for over
a year
that's so nice i appreciate it i love
you too replied
seriously it's actually me wikipedia
says schnapp's desire for acting started
when he was about five years old after
watching the broadway production of
annie
that's not really where i found my love
for acting but i did
say that a few times because i thought
that was like a better
story but the real place i like got into
acting was
when i took an acting class when i was
like six years old and then
i did it for two years and then the
acting teacher recommended me to
try out acting so i was like why don't i
try this out so i went for it
schnapp voiced the lead character
charlie brown in 2015's the peanuts
movie
schnapp's first on-screen role was in
steven spielberg's historical drama
bridge of spies along with tom hanks
that's fact in the beginning of my
career i was doing a bunch of stuff like
commercials and voiceovers and little
things and i was like
like do i really like this and then all
of a sudden i did this charlie brown
movie which was crazy
and then i did this spielberg movie with
tom hanks like all in the same time and
i remember having my 10th birthday on
set with tom hanks so it was just all
happened so fast
and i knew right from then right after i
worked with tom hanks i was like i want
to do this forever
imdb born it says october 3rd 2004 new
york city
new york that's fact my birth name noah
cameron schnapp yeah fun fact
i was actually thinking like right when
i started stranger things
to change like to have a stage name like
noah cameron because it sounds better
but i never did it and now i'm stuck
with those schnapps so
height five nine sadly
that's true but i just went to the
doctor and they said i'm still growing
so
i've got time noah has a twin sister
chloe yeah
he's four minutes older than chloe when
they were like trying to
take me out of my mom i had this thing
called jaundice and they had to like put
me in a window
so good story there next up quora
do you think noah schnapp will be taller
than finn wolfhard by the end of season
four
finn's tall i mean i hope so
i i want want to be tall i just want to
be like six feet tall i feel like that
i feel like six feet is just if i if you
can say that
or even just 5 11 so i can round up next
one where does noah snap live
in new york i love it here reddit
fans of will buyers in this sub what are
you hoping to see from him in season
four
pockets fancy reply i'm hoping for a
will hell duo
they haven't had many if any one-on-one
scenes or conversations
they both have a specific experience
with the upside down that the other kids
don't have and that could bond them as
you
can see if you watch the third season at
the end
will and 11 kind of move away together
so i would definitely expect
more from them together which is pretty
exciting me and millie have
a lot of fun on set so it'll be good
that's it guys thanks for the questions
i will be signing off the internet